make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are at the conclusion of the
Thanos imperative yes we are we are at
the end of this story and the ending is
on very it is so cool okay so Thanos
giving up and joining the side of Marvel
and the revenge's and the cancerverse
people we're kind of freaking out about
it they were starting to kind of lose
their minds and here's a funny thing
about this Marvel's response is like
thank you I appreciate everything that
you're doing to help me out you know
I'll take you and I'll take all your
friends and all of my guys are like all
my mini angled ones are so anxious to
meet you what this means is a mini
angled ones can basically transcend the
existing universe and move into another
universe remember multiversal conquests
is the name of the game going from one
universe to the next conquering it and
taking it over the other question was
how in the world were they able to kill
the avatar of death in the first place
was it just means of overpowering them
with with cosmic energy or anything like
that no it was basically an artifact a
weapon that was provided to Marvel by
the many evil ones themselves
specifically by Shu McGrath now this
kind of requires us to get into a bit of
discussion about the nature of Shimoga
wrath right so if you go back and you
look at like 1970 you look in 1981 by
1970 you had a slimming tower it was
issue number 6 but it was written by
Wally wood and the idea was that he was
the one that first kind of referenced
the Dark Gods so to speak in the Marvel
Comics are you going to Bruce Jones in
1981 with a Conan story and you get like
the Dark One's you know the old ones
that kind of a thing it was always kind
of Marvel eluding over the year so there
were like these Dark Gods that were out
there it wasn't really until Grant
Morrison with Zenith and it wasn't
really until you started getting into
like Doctor Strange stories with with
Shue McGrath that these old ones these
dark primordial gods sort of kind of
getting a form the idea of referring to
them as the many angled ones in in this
one and in cancerverse and Thanos
imperative is actually a relatively new
concept but all it's designed to do is
kind of consolidate all this information
down and to say the Shu McGrath is one
of many of these beings that exist out
there in the space between universes but
unlike a lot of these many angled ones
if there is a hierarchy we don't really
know about it but we do know that Shu
McGrath for the most part led them now
in terms of how Shu McGrath ties into
this it could largely kind of be assumed
that like multiple occasions where sumo
growth was always sort of trying to
break into the main Marvel Universe this
is yet another instance you know the
difference is that Shiva McGrath was
always kind of a multiversal entity and
that because he resides in this
between universes he doesn't really
belong to a particular universe right so
he can kind of move between universes as
he as he sees fit as he can it just
happens to be with a lot of the dr.
strange stories or at least they're
really old stories he was always trying
to pass him to the main Marvel Universe
conquer it since that's where he ruled
at one point and they kind of branch out
from there right but one of the things
that's kind of been hit on with the idea
of the the cancerverse is that Xu
McGrath and the many angled ones have
conquered multiple other universes right
this is just one in a long line of
different universes they're trying to
take over some of them are much much
darker and far more screwed up in this
one and some of them remain untouched
right so it's one of those strange
situations but giving a Marvel a sword
by which he can kill the avatar of death
is magically empowered and that's one of
the things to understand here is that
well you do have cosmic entities and you
do have various beings out there that
are wildly powerful you do also have a
lot of demons and things like that that
are equally powerful right so there that
you know the cosmic entities aren't
really like the Grand Poobah the buck
doesn't stop there there's a lot of
beings out there that are equally
powerful to them right it's one of the
things we didn't really include
and the Marvel cosmic hierarchy is like
a lot of the demons and monsters that
are equal to a lot of the cosmic
entities and we probably should you know
it kind of kind of do because we need to
do a new cosmic hierarchy anyway so
we'll probably go ahead and jump into
that but the idea here is using this
sword that was given to him by the many
angled ones Marvel in turn stabs Thanos
and so what it does is it jumps to that
basically the opening of the fault and
then it basically picks up with the
Galactus engine and the idea here is
that with with this basically being kind
of a warped and and screwed up version
of Galactus himself from the main Marvel
Universe but albeit from a different
reality what it does is it actually seed
a lot of the other cosmic entities stand
aside and it loves Galactus to engage in
a conflict with this now the reason why
is because Galactus unlike a lot of
these other cosmic entities really kind
of takes it as like a personal a
personal battle at a personal struggle
more so than that the Galactus really
seems you one of the few left standing a
lot of the other cosmic entities either
been destroyed or they've left for
example Aaron the judge of the
Celestials was destroyed or at least
seemed to be destroyed in this conflict
and so a lot of the Celestials have been
obliterated a lot of the other cosmic
entities have been destroyed Galactus is
one of the last few standing and so
ultimately what ends up happening here
with all these other these other forces
that are here the Shiar what they end up
doing is saying okay then our job here
is to focus on the Galactus engine this
is the single biggest threat that we had
to face here everything else is cleanup
duty and comparison to this but this is
the biggest threat because
this is what can wipe out the cosmic
entities and sort of joining all their
forces together and and working to try
to destroy the Galactus engine at the
end of the day all they're really able
to do is kind of offer some measure of
aid but they're not really able to do it
on their own right because there's just
too much power for them to contain so
that's the nature of the conflict at the
moment right now it looks like all hope
is lost
we have tano's who essentially joined
forces and is into sacrificing himself
to Marvel you have all these forces you
have like almost all the cosmic entities
who in a lot of ways have been destroyed
you've got Galactus is one of the few
left 1/2 the forces that are there have
been totally eradicated just by the
forces of the cancerverse coming out not
even like Galactus engine itself and
then once Galactus and the other cosmic
entities are destroyed then every
Solly's of the forces will be wiped out
I mean for the most part all hope is
lost here it's bleak it's one of these
things where like everybody's going to
die now of course
Nova's showing up here and offering a
helping hand it's cool but he's my know
me powerful enough on his own to save
the day and the real gambit here the
real trick comes by way of Thanos and
this is why this is why one is called
the Thanos imperative and to wife a
knows in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
was painfully underplayed because thou
is exceedingly intelligent he's one of
the smartest people out there in the
Marvel Universe in terms of battle
strategy and all those things and the
reason why is because remember all this
this conflict with Danos to the vendors
and all that stuff is taking place
inside the can servers and so ultimately
what he does is he begins to kind of
tease and toy with Marvel and say you're
so much like my main Marvel counterpart
and when the question is asked why is it
because Marvel always jumped headlong
into his goal and he never really
considered the consequences he never
really thought about what it was that he
was doing by killing me here in your
universe all you've done is invite
mistress death you've brought death to a
universe where people can't die were you
killed the mistress death that's here
you've sealed your own fate it's the
smartest gambit that could have been
made here the smartest thing that could
have been done because Thanos saw this
coming and it was part of his plan the
entire time right I mean it was
something that kind of came to fruition
as soon as Santos realized that he was
banned for the realm of mistress death
and he couldn't die it's why he
instigated the fight without with Drax
the destroyer was to test that theory
what's his test the theory can he die
you know as the avatar of death and as
someone who had been banned from the
realm of mistress death what would
happen if his physical body was
destroyed would it reconstitute itself
would he be kind of left is some sort of
spiritual essence whatever the case was
it was a huge
to take but that was the idea behind it
was to basically engage into a fight
with Drax the destroyer let doctors
destroy or kill him and then see what
happens the fact that his physical body
resurrected meant the Thanos himself
could not truly die his physical form
would always return meaning he could go
to the can servers he could lead Marvel
to his location if Marvel was anything
like the main Marvel Universe version
that they must have fought so many times
he would have done exactly what he did
Thanos knew exactly what he would do
which is exactly what he did and jump
the gun celebrate in the fact that oh my
god I finally got the avatar of death
let's kill him and give no thought to
like what happens if we do kill him in
this location the smart move would have
been to take Thanos to the main Marvel
Universe and kill him there because in
that way mistress death wouldn't have
been teleported it wouldn't have been
brought to that universe but remember
it's the nature of mistress death as the
person who gathers the souls of those
who have died to travel to their
location and to bring them to where
they're supposed to be is exactly what
it up happening with regards to the
original Marvel and so because of that
with this version of Marvel having
brought mistress death to his universe
she in turn kills him and then wipes out
everything is supposed to die everything
they're supposed to be cleared out and
because this is a universe where
everything is supposed to be dead even
though it's not ultimately the entire
universe ends up getting wiped out by
mistress stuff it's all cleanse and it's
all cleared out right like everything in
that universe is for the most part
destroyed or at least is what it seems
and so far as the universe begins to
collapse in on itself all the members
who were there as part of the
cancerverse
either inside the cancerverse universe
or in the main Marvel Universe are
killed the Galactus engine itself begins
to be pulled back in the many angled
ones seemed a more or less retreat or be
eradicated themselves essentially the
day appears to be one and this is where
things begin to go awry because what
happens here is Thanos turns to mistress
death and says I fulfilled my purpose as
your avatar I've done these things to
please you will you talk to me a
mistress death still turns away mistress
death still says no it's the age-old
struggle between Thanos and mistress
death he's trying to get her attention
and she won't give it to him
and so as a result of that he begins to
lash out the crazy thing about this is
Stannis is now in a maddened state which
means when all these forces start
getting teleported out of this location
if Thanos goes with them or if Thanos
makes it through the rift and returns
back to the main Marvel Universe who
knows what he's gonna do because he's
angry and he's heartbroken let's just go
on some warpath and start killing
everything he can find but because of
that what ends up happening here is Nova
in star-lord enough stage
hunt the Cosmic Cube as it was brought
in by star-lord for just just for this
kind of situation in case it was needed
with what little power it has left is
basically used in channel for the
purpose of keeping Thanos contained
keeping Thanos subdued and so as the
entire universe begins collapsing in
down around them and as the fault begins
to seal and as everything's cut off
ultimately Richard Ryder and Peter quill
stay behind in the cancerverse with
Thanos and are basically trapped there
and ultimately the day is saved right so
because of the sacrifice of these two
guys the entire cancerverse is more or
less defeated the victory is won by the
various superheroes and of course a
statue is made in their name but the big
takeaway from this and the thing that
kind of left a lot of people asking was
what comes next what happens with
star-lord what happened with Richard
Rider
and what happens with Thanos are they
gone from the Marvel landscape forever
or are they going to make a return well
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain it make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like this was
an amazing story and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]